Anabelle is about the doll from the
conjuring it's about how it ended up in
that creepy office of creepy stuff in
that movie and what happened before it
the family that first encountered that
thing this movie is not directed by
James Wan however it is directed by his
preferred cinematographer a choice since
dead silence this is not the first time
however that this director has got to
direct the next installment in a
franchise after having been just a
cinematographer on the first one he was
the director of photography for the
original Mortal Kombat film and the
director of Mortal Kombat annihilation
he also directed butterfly effect to so
everyone was like Chris go check out the
trailer for annabelle it actually looks
like a really good horror movie it's a
spin-off to the conjuring the conjuring
was awesome it's the director of
photography of the conjuring and
insidious and insidious - it's gonna be
great it's not this movie's ass now if
you have not been watching my videos for
a while you do not know that I thought
the conjuring was one of the best horror
films so far this decade I loved
insidious and I even thought insidious -
is pretty good so there is no real
reason why I shouldn't want to like this
movie and I do want to like this movie
but the movie is filled and populated
with the idiotic characters that are so
so dumb you just can't care about them
at all it's such a predictable scary
movie - because you have this sweet
loving couple you know there have a baby
on the way everything's perfect they're
smiling all the time he's a doctor they
have tons of money where is this money
come from who knows but they are so
wonderful and happy together and of
course they get this doll who in the
hell would bring this thing into their
house I was just waiting for some
character to come into the scene and be
like dude why do you have that doll that
is the creepiest looking doll I have
ever seen in my life who in the world
would put that in their baby's room
right over there carriage no one in the
right mind would ever have that doll but
it's a horror film okay it's meant to
scare you does it scare you there are
some effective moments I think if you
are more of a lightweight when it comes
to scary movies this movie is going to
have you crapping your pants it's jump
scare after jump scare with this movie
the scares were so obvious because
there'd be like a really wide shot with
a character sitting on a couch and then
over on the left side of the frame is an
open doorway and you can see down a hall
you know sums in a walk by the hall you
just know what's going to happen I was
like there were times in this movie
where I would just look over and
whatever was obviously about to happen
and it would happen because there's not
that much suspense building in the
actual filmmaking and the construction
of the scary scenes there's a ton of
sound effects that are supposed to make
you feel as if something scary is
happening but the filmmaking doesn't
work hand in hand with that because it
was so obvious whenever a scare was
about to take place that there's really
only one or two effective moments in
this movie particularly an elevator
staircase sequence that I actually
thought was really cool besides that the
scares in this movie just didn't scare
me at all
the characters were dull wooden and
lifeless I didn't give a crap about
anyone in this movie they were the
stupidest horror characters ever where a
wife goes hey you should probably call
the police honey because there was a
scream next door and he's like no they
would just want us to come over and look
they wouldn't want us to call the police
I'll go check by myself
do you hear a scream next door and all
the lights in the house go out of course
you call the police you don't go into
their house by yourself another really
dumb moment is when the lead woman is
talking to a police officer about his
investigation into a murder two people
were murdered by a cult in the area she
asks the officer did you look into the
cult and he goes why would you want me
to investigate the cult I don't know
maybe because they murdered two people
right next door to the woman and then
came in her house and tried to kill her
too maybe that's why you should
investigate the cult this movie is
really dumb I'm sorry like this movie
had some scary moments it had some
creepy moments it was slightly better
directed than some other horror films
out there but it is a really dumb movie
with predictable scares that was just
kind of boring in all honesty Annabelle
was a very disappointing movie it is not
even close to being as good as the
conjuring was and I'm going to give
Annabelle a D so guys if you did see the
conjuring what did you think of that
movie do you agree with me that's a
pretty damn good horror film and if you
do decide to see Annabelle would you
think of that one too guys also I am in
the middle of doing my David Fincher
series of reviews leading up to gone
girl this Thursday I've already reviewed
seven Fight Club the game and panic room
soon I'll be bringing you
reviews for zodiac Benjamin Button the
social network and Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo before Thursday I've got a lot of
work to do but I do hope you guys stick
with me on those videos and enjoy
watching them as I look at David
Fincher's career in retrospective form
thanks as always for watching guys and
if you liked this you can click right
here and get stuck Munoz